The World Premiere is
in your home Friday.
>> Greg: DISASTER DESTROYS
MANY THINGS INCLUDING ILLUSIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE PEOPLE ASSUME
BUSINESS OWNERS ARE RICH.
HARDLY.
ON THE CONTRARY PROFIT MARGINS
ARE SO THIN THEY COULD BE BLOWN
OVER.
FOR THE TIME THIS IS OVERCOME A
NIGHT OUT WILL BE HEADING TO
7-ELEVEN TO BUY BEANS.
WE WORRY ABOUT WAITRESSES AND
SERVERS AND OF COURSE EVERY
TAVERNS I SEE A SPECIALIST, THE
BARTENDER.
BUT TO HELP THEM TO HAVE TO HELP
THE OWNERS FIRST.
IT’S LIKE AN AIRLINE EMERGENCY,
THE PARENT HAS TO PUT ON THE
OXYGEN MASK BEFORE HE OR SHE
HELPS THE KIDS.
THE GUY WHO OWNS THE BAR NEEDS
HELP FIRST SO HE CAN PAY HAS
SOME STAFF.
IF NOT, YOU END UP WITH BOARDED
UP THE STOREFRONTS AND A
BUSTLING STREET BECOME SKID ROW.
TOWNS DIED THIS WAY.
THE SOLUTION?
GLAD YOU ASKED.
I WANT TO BALANCE MY CHECKBOOK.
SO PRESIDENT TRUMP IF YOU ARE
LISTENING, AND I KNOW YOU ARE
COME FIRST TO GOVERNMENT NEEDS
TO MAKE THE LOANS DIRECTLY TO
THE OWNER.
IF THE OWNER CAN PAY BACK ITS ON
HIM OR HER.
THEY DID THIS AFTER 9/11 AND IT
WORKED.
THE LOAN SHOULD ALSO HAVE A LONG
PAYBACK.
IT TO READ HIS THOUGHTS OF
SUICIDE.
BECAUSE OF THAT SORT THAT CAN
LEAD.
THE SECOND PART IN INVOLVES YOU,
THE VIEWER.
YOU NEED TO GO OUT AND SPEND IT
AND GET THAT OXYGEN PUMPING INTO
THE SYSTEM.
BUT FIRST YOU DESERVE AN
INCENTIVE.
SO HOW ABOUT FOR ONE YEAR WE
MAKE MEALS AND BEVERAGES TAX
DEDUCTIBLE.
TAKE BAR TABS AND MARK THEM ALL
SELF ENTERTAINMENT.
IF YOUR FAMILY GOES OUT AND
SPENDS 200 BUCKS, YOU GET 60
BACK LATER.
LET’S PUT THE FUN AND REFUND.
BECAUSE IF WE DON’T YOU COULD
LOSE YOUR FAVORITE BAR, WHICH
SUCKS BECAUSE AFTER ALL THIS
YOU’RE GOING TO NEED A DRINK.
YOU KNOW, JUAN, THE REASON I
THINK THIS IS SO AN IMPORTANT IS
BECAUSE ONE PLACES YOU GO TO AT
NIGHT CLOSE, YOU LOSE THE FOOT
TRAFFIC AND THEN THE STREETS ARE
EMPTY AND IT BECOMES THE DANGER
ZONE.
>> Juan: YEAH, IT BECOMES A
GHOST TOWN.
IT’S SHOCKING, IT’S LIKE WHERE
IS THE LIFE, WHERE IS THE PARTY?
I JUST THINK WE HAVE TO GIVE
CONSUMERS THE KIND OF CONFIDENCE
AND THE INCENTIVES TO GO OUT AND
SPEND, BECAUSE THEY DRIVE OUR
ECONOMY.
MAYBE PEOPLE AREN’T AWARE OF IT
FOR CONSUMER SPENDING IS THE
PRIME ENGINE OF THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY.
I WILL SAY THAT FOR BIG
COMPANIES, A LOT OF THE BIG
BUSINESSES WANT TO REOPEN BUT
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT THEY
ALSO HAVE LIABILITY CONCERNS.
IF THEY BRING EMPLOYEES BACK IN
AND THEN THERE’S A WAVE OF
INFECTIONS OR PROBLEMS OR EVEN
PEOPLE DYING, THEN THEY WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE.
THEY HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THAT
AND WE DON’T WANT AS DR. BROOKS
WAS SUGGESTING AND WHAT WE SAW
IN THE LETTER A BLOCK THERE, WE
DON’T WANT TO RISK THAT WE WOULD
HAVE A SECOND WAVE COMPARABLE TO
THE FIRST WAVE BECAUSE WE HAVE
SLOWED DOWN ON THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING, HAND WASHING AND
OTHER MITIGATION MEASURES WE
HAVE TAKEN THAT HAVE PROVEN
EFFECTIVE.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW JESSE, YOU
TALK TO PRESIDENT TRUMP ALMOST
EVERY DAY ON THAT SECRET THAT
PHONE.
NEXT TIME YOU TALK TO HIM, CAN
YOU PLEAD WITH HIM TO INTRODUCE
THE DEDUCTION SO THEY CAN
ELIMINATE ALL THE HOOPS THAT
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS HAVE
JUMPED THROUGH?
THEY WILL BE RESPONSIBLE, JUST
CUT OUT ALL THE RED TAPE.
>> Jesse: I LOVE HOW
GREG GUTFELD HAS MADE FOOD AND
ALCOHOL D A CENTERPIECE FOR THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY PACKAGE.
THAT IS GREG GUTFELD RIGHT
THERE.
I’M KIND OF TORN BECAUSE EMMA
HAS LEARNED HOW TO COOK DURING
THE PANDEMIC SO GOING OUT TO
DINNER IS NOT -- I’M GOING TO DO
MY BEST AND I’M GOING TO GO OUT
AS MUCH IS POSSIBLE TO SAVE THE
COUNTRY JUST LIKE I’M STAYING
AND SAVING THE COUNTRY NOW BY
STAYING HOME AND WATCHING
TELEVISION.
BUT IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, THERE’S
A POST EXPOSURE TEST.
YOU CAN PRICK YOUR FINGER IN THE
COMFORT OF YOUR OWN HOME AND YOU
SEE IF YOU’VE BEEN INFECTED WITH
THE VIRUS.
IF YOU HAVE BEEN INFECTED IT’S
SAFER FOR YOU TO GO BACK TO WORK
AND, YOUR BLOOD CAN THEN BE
ADMINISTERED TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUFFERING AND THOSE ANTIBODIES
CAN HELP THEM RECOVER AND THAT
TEST I BELIEVE IS GOING TO DRIVE
POLICY AND TERMS OF REOPENING
THE COUNTRY.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW EMILY, I
THINK PEOPLE HAVE A MISGUIDED
ASSUMPTION OF THE BUSINESS
OWNER.
WHEN THEY THINK YOU OWN A
BUSINESS, THEY THINK YOU ARE
RICH WHEN MORE THAN LIKELY YOU
ARE SLEEPING ON FLOORS AND NOT
TAKING A PAYCHECK.
YOU KNOW?
THESE GUYS NEED HELP.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YOU GUYS TALKED ABOUT THIS
BEFORE BUT I GOT SOME COMMENTS
JUST FROM MY OWN FAMILY SMALL
BUSINESS, THAT’S A PRIVILEGE
SITUATION.
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS DO
EVERYTHING FROM TOP DOWN TO THE
BOTTOM.
I DON’T WANT TO SOUND LIKE A
DEBBIE DOWNER BUT THE PROBLEM
WITH THE PAYROLL PER PROTECTION
PROGRAM, ONE OF THE MAJOR ISSUES
AS IT DOESN’T ALIGN WITH THE
REGULATION FACING EVERY SEGMENT
OF THE HOSPITALIT INDUSTRY.
YOU KIND OF REDUCE IT TO FOOD
AND ALCOHOL WHICH WE LOVE BUT
THE REALITY IS THE SON
$900 BILLION INDUSTRY.
THAT’S OVER 2% OF OUR GDP SO WE
ABSOLUTELY SHOULD DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO MAINTAIN IT AND ALSO
TO STIMULATE IT.
ON THURSDAY, THE TREASURY
REVISED IT.
THE REDUCE THE MAJORITY PORTION
OF THE UNFORGIVABLE AMOUNT OF
THE LOAN AND ALSO THE LIMITS ON
THE FORGIVABLE PORTION ON THE
COST.
THAT GOES BACK TO WHAT WE WERE
DOING TALKING ABOUT BEFORE WHICH
IS THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS AND
THOSE OPERATORS HAVE TO SPEND
75% OF THE COST ON PAYROLL.
BUT THEIR DOORS ARE CLOSED.
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY BEING GUTTED
AND MANY OF THEM ARE APPEALING
BY THE WAY DIRECTLY TO THEIR
SENATORS BECAUSE THERE IS NO WAY
THAT ANY OF THESE FDA TELEPHONE
LINES, THEY ARE TOTALLY CLOGGED.
SO IT’S LIKE WHO WILL HEAR ME
RIGHT NOW?
MEANWHILE OTHER APPLICABLE
BUSINESS OWNERS DON’T EVEN --
THEY DON’T HAVE THAT SAME COST
REVENUE BUT THEY ALSO APPLY.
I WILL SAY THAT THE TONE IN THE
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY IS ONE OF
PANIC AND DEVASTATION AND IT’S
NOT POSITIVE.
AGAIN, I DON’T WANT TO BE A
FEARMONGERING BUT TO HIGHLIGHT
THIS IS A VERY REAL SITUATION
THAT NEEDS REAL SOLUTIONS.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, I HATE YOU
EMILY BECAUSE I WAS A BETTER
MONOLOGUE THAN MINE.
YOU EXPLAINED IT FAR BETTER THAN
I DID.
DANA, DO YOU MISS YOUR
BARTENDERS AND YOUR WAITRESSES
AND YOUR SERVERS LIKE I DO?
>> Dana: YES.
AND EVEN OTHER PEOPLE.
LIKE MY DOG WALKER.
IT’S GREAT TO HAVE JASPER HERE
AND EVERYTHING BUT SHE HAS A
BUSINESS AND THEY ABSOLUTELY
NEED HELP.
I WILL ADD TO OTHER THINGS THAT
I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION AND
CONGRESS SHOULD CONSIDER.
THIS IS SUPER UNPOPULAR JUST TO
KEEP ON THE THEME OF THE WEEK.
I WOULD DO A CAPITAL GAINS TAX
CUT BECAUSE IF YOU WANT PEOPLE
TO PUMP MONEY INTO THE ECONOMY
AND BUY THINGS AND INVEST IN
THINGS THAT HELP WITH THINGS,
WELL THEN ALLOW PEOPLE HAVE
EARNED SOME SORT OF RETURN ON
THEIR INVESTMENT TO BE ABLE TO
SPEND THAT INVESTMENT AND NOT BE
ABLE TO WORRY ABOUT IT BEING
TAXED TO DEATH.
THE SECOND THING I WOULD SAY IS
I THINK THEY SHOULD CONSIDER
INCREASING THE CHARITABLE TAX
DEDUCTION FOR THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THERE ARE A LOT
OF ENTITIES THAT NEED HELP.
I TALKED TO A FAMILY TODAY THAT
RUNS A BABY PANTRY OUT OF THEIR
CHURCH AND THEY ARE DESPERATE
FOR HELP.
SO PROVIDING PEOPLE WITH THE
MEANS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
INCENTIVE TO ALSO GIVE WOULD GO
A LONG WAY.
THE GOVERNMENT IS ALREADY DOING
A LOT AND I KNOW THERE WOULD BE
SOME OF THE LEFT THAT SAY, HOW
DARE YOU DO THAT?
WELL PEOPLE WITH MONEY CAN’T
HELP ACTUALLY GET THAT BACK ON
TRACK.
AND, THE PEOPLE ON THE LOWER
RUNGS OF THE LATTER WERE LOSING
WHAT THEY HAVE.
THE PEOPLE ON THE HIGHER END OF
THE LATTER CAN SUSTAIN IT, AND
THEREFORE IT’S THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE PEOPLE ON
THE HIGHER RUNGS TO SPEND A LOAD
OF MONEY SO THE PEOPLE ON THE
LOWER RUNGS.
BUT I WAS THINKING, THOSE SHORTS
THAT JESSE HAD IN THAT TSA, THEY
ARE SO PINK AND SO WONDERFUL, I
JUST DON’T KNOW.
YOU CAN HOOK ME UP?
>> Jesse: I STILL HAVE THEM
ON.
RIGHT HERE, BABY.